hey your silver here and welcome back to
planet soo today's episode is all about
the lengthy long boys of the African
savanna giraffes and honestly when I
started recording this video I wasn't
really expecting it to turn into four
habitat build I just had this idea for a
giraffe shelter which I really wanted to
try and just start recording and figured
I would see where it went from there
honestly I still don't have much of a
plan for my content and just doing what
I feel like and experimenting with the
game a bit and hopefully it turns into a
presentable video at some point and I
guess Here I am today again with an idea
that I wanted to show off so I'm working
on a giraffe house and in a little bit
on a general giraffe habitat as well and
this was inspired in particular by the
Savannah house in flydoor
in Rotterdam which I believe is the most
visited sue in the Netherlands and they
have this very contemporary modern
giraffe house which uses very
traditional textures and elements which
I think looks really cool it has an
overall round shape kind of pointy and
tall actually and I just really loved
the composition of this building and I
wanted to do something similar in the
game as well and just see where I could
take it so I ended up building a bit of
a more dark textured building as opposed
to very lights wooden beams that they
use this one's a bit lower as well ended
up making mine a lot more round and low
and also and this is I think the biggest
difference and the most interesting
thing about this build is I wanted to
add mushroom be a patterns around it now
mush Rabia are are a type of
architectural element in the Arabic
world they're kind of like Oriole
windows or balconies almost in a sense
with these decorated patterns all over
them I'm just gonna put up a picture
right now to show you what these things
generally look like I got a lot of
comments recently asking me to bring up
pictures of stuff that I'm talking about
so this is what these kind of things
look like and I think they're really
interesting they look really cool and
they're they're certainly a way
I think to make this build a bit more
semantically fits to the habitat of
giraffes because even though of course
this is still not the type of building
that a giraffe would realistically live
in in the natural world it's based on
patterns and buildings that I saw in
Mombasa in Kenya in particular this one
apartment building which has much more
be a panther hands all over it and I
think it would be a cool way to give
this very modern structure a sort of
localized look as well and also while
real-life mush repeat patterns are very
symmetrical and looping and really based
on a strict sense of geometry very much
like Arabic architecture in general you
can often find your metric patterns very
similar to this in tiles and textiles
and just all over a rabbit culture but
yeah I thought it would be really cool
also because with the way that I'm doing
this which is a bit more organic and
loosely done then real mush for beer
would be it also kind of resembles the
texture of a giraffe skin so I thought
that would be really cool too
I don't know kind of reflects the the
culture and the the nature of giraffes
themselves and and make this big glassy
structure feel a bit more local and a
bit more part of the habitats than it
otherwise would have been if it were
just a big glass structure with wooden
beams so yeah that's basically what this
episode revolves around and at this
point the building is already finished
because honestly it's quite easy to
build things like this with the with the
dome trick I guess as I should call it
now I know a lot of people watching this
haven't watched my planet coaster videos
so I'm just gonna try to explain this
the best I can but in planet coaster
there has always been a very popular
trick to create domes and spires and
other symmetrical elements which is to
take one grid piece that is a piece that
spawns a grid and that stays on the grid
in the game and build one side of a dome
or aspire or any
kind of multi-directional symmetrical
building that you want to make on one
side of this piece and then once you're
done making that one part of it you copy
it around to the other side grab the
whole structure and because of the way
that selecting things works in planets
coaster and planets do the game just
grabs the center points between these
two Center repeat scenery pieces and
once you start rotating this and place
it down
each time you rotate it you can just
basically make any symmetrical round
shape that you want
so this is a trick that a lot of people
have always used to create domes and
spires but I think it could also work
for a round building like this so that's
why this whole experimentation kind of
started happening as well unfortunately
you can't actually make you desig domes
with this trick because the glass starts
intersecting itself in some strange ways
but I'm still trying to work on how to
make periodic domes I've put way too
much time into this but I really want to
figure out how to make geodesic domes in
this game at some point I'll get there
hopefully and even though it's
impossible to do it with the the in-game
pieces because they're equilateral
triangles or Pentagon's or hexagons I'm
gonna try and break this at some point
anyway to try and get on topic a little
bit more this was just how I was
inspired to build its building and how I
built it in the end and how I was able
to build it so quickly as well but for
the rest of this episode I'm going to
focus on the rest of the habitats
starting here with a viewing platform
and shelter for guests and the idea
behind this platform was to make it like
these platforms that you find very often
in real life zoos where guests can have
very close interaction with the giraffes
because ideally you should be exactly at
neck Heights with the giraffes now in
the game I had to do a bit of trial and
error on this eye or so I thought
actually to try and get the height right
because it's really difficult to figure
out exactly how tall the giraffe will be
and
to what height they will come if you're
looking at them from this platform but
somehow I managed to get it right right
away so yeah hopefully if all goes well
we will see some giraffes coming up to
this platform and having some
interaction with guests now I can
already spoil that the game was not
actually programmed to do this you don't
get people petting the giraffes or
feeding them or things like this as you
would see in real-life Seuss but
sometimes I get lucky enough and get a
giraffe coming up to the people and then
they will actually look at their hands
and they'll point upwards the guests I
mean not the giraffes and have some sort
of guest interaction which i think is
super cool and I'll have some footage of
that at the end of this video but mostly
I just wanted to build this structure
because realistically it's something
that you find in a lot of giraffe
habitats in real life as well and I want
to give it up to frontier for adding
these detailed thatched roof pieces in
the African theme because they're really
cool thatched roof pieces are something
that I still feel were sorely missing in
planet coaster even though there were
some they were not nearly as detailed
and realistic as these ones so I'm
really happy that these are in the game
they're definitely really useful for
Polynesian or African or any kind of
tropical theme like that Indonesian or I
don't know I'm still working out ideas
for that but yeah I think they're really
cool now aside from that the only thing
really separating the guests and the
giraffes is just this ditch with rock
work on the guest side and a gentle
slope on the side of the giraffes as you
often find in real life suits as well
just to be able to provide the guests
with an unobstructed view of the
giraffes now it's just something I want
to mention I'm sorry about all of the
steam notifications popping up in the
top right corner I'm still gonna have to
figure out how to hide those I know I
might sound a bit like a noob at the
moment for somebody who has a YouTube
channel but honestly I had to start
recording in bandicam because for some
reason dxtory doesn't record the game
and I've been counting on the X story
for a while even in
my cheat engine footage of planet
coaster when no other program could
still record it but the egg story but
for some reason it doesn't work anymore
on planets ooh and now I'm gonna have to
settle for bandicam and I'm still kinda
used to it
shoutout for to really rent kemal for
giving me the tip that bandicam actually
works because I had no idea what program
to even record this game with at first
but yeah I'm still trying to get used to
it and trying to see how I should
actually record my footage so I'm sorry
if it's not as good of a quantity as
you're used to from me I'm still setting
up a sort of new workflow now anyway I
kind of want to talk about ethics and
the giraffe habitat specifically in a
bit after that as well because there was
this really interesting discussion then
I got involved with in the bro nation
discord yesterday about the ethics of
zoos and to an extent this matters in
game because I do think no matter your
opinion about the existence of zoos and
how ethical you think they are and
whether or not they can be ethical
planet Zoo is just a game so I think
these considerations are not that
important not nearly as much as they are
in real life when real animals come into
play but still there is the question I
think of whether you should try and make
your zoos in Planet sue as ethical as
possible or whether it's also ok to just
build unethical zoos if they look good
if they look good and if that's the
point of what you're trying to do and
personally I think it's all about
awareness to what extent you're aware of
how ethical what you're building is
because if you're trying to build a good
zoo and if you're trying to take care of
your animals well I think you do kind of
need to put in the effort to at least
learn about them what kind of habitats
they need learn to care for their needs
not even necessarily only in the game
and in terms of these statistics of the
animals but even in real life what kind
of things would work in a zoo and what
wouldn't be good practices and
personally I think that as somebody with
the privilege of having quite a large
audience I would also just like to use
this game as
a way to explore the ideas of what makes
Zoo design and specifically habitat
design good and ethical because I don't
know I feel like if I if I were to make
habitats that are completely unethical
and really just focused on on making
them look good I would give a wrong
image of what zoos are about and what
zoo should be and given that I guess
with the audience that I have my videos
will be some sort of example for people
to follow I want to make sure that I use
at least common sense and I make it a
good example and maybe even use it as a
way to educate myself and other people
about design because honestly for me
creative simulation games like this I've
always been a way to explore things
about the real world as well I've
learned so much about the theme parks
through rollercoaster country and planet
coaster and I've learned so much about
urban planning through city skylines
honestly it's what inspired me to study
urban studies to this day so I think
games like this honestly have a power to
inspire and educate people and given
that facts I would like to make my zoos
also as ethical as possible and try to
use them as a way to explore real knife
Sioux designs which maybe is a bit
pretentious and I guess it is but at the
end of the day I'm just a nerd like that
and that's the kind of stuff I find
interesting and I just like learning
about the things that appear in creative
games so I don't know that's my
perspective but I'm certainly not going
to stop anyone from building unethical
zoos if they want that or maybe even use
that as an exploration of what's a bad
practice in terms of zoo design but for
those that do want to focus on caring
for their animals and seeing how in the
real world zoos should be designed with
ethical considerations in mind that's
the kind of thing that I want to do as
well now with that in mind
oops I dropped my USB stick sorry about
the noise with that in mind I'm working
on a sort of thanks
holding area behind the shelter building
here just to have a place where the
giraffes could be cared for and where
you might have staff section or a
kitchen anything like that all the kind
of facilities that you would typically
find right next to a habitat as opposed
to in a separate building like in Planet
Zoo where animals get carried through
the separate building in a tiny little
box which of course is is a way that
planets who has to tackle finding a
balance between realism and gameplay but
I'd like to at least have suspense of
disbelief that there is some kind of
realistic design involved so I want to
at least include some backstage set
sections to some minimal degree as well
and god I I kind of lost track of what I
was talking about so yeah I just added
that holding area at the back but there
will also be some separated areas within
the shelter dome like building itself I
actually opted for calling this building
the onion I suppose because to me this
thing really looks like an onion
sometimes you even do get onions that
are kind of shaped like this there are
just really fat and thick and not as
round as onions typically are and you
know especially if you cut off the top
because you're starting to chop it or
whenever an onion it kind of looks like
this on its side I guess so yeah this
building looks like an onion I think so
honestly that's just what I'm gonna call
it and the rest of this habitat is a
really quite standard I feel I'm not
really exploring too much the part of
the ethical discussion was also about to
extent you should just really focus on
copying real-life zoos or try and find a
way to make it better because you know
in in a game like planet coaster you can
just wildly copy theme parks in real
life and it'll be realistic and probably
quite good but in a game like this I
think you also have to put some
consideration in terms of how good you
think the zoo is that you're trying to
get inspiration from art I guess that's
why I was feeling a bit guilty about
basing this habitat just on the general
appearance
of giraffe habitats in zoos around the
world but at the same time they are all
very similar and as far as I've been
able to tell - Raph's
are some of the easier animals to take
care of and keep in a zoo even though of
course their behavior will be different
from the natural environment they seem
to be better than a lot of animals are
in in terms of be living in captivity
there are just some slight difference
which is a differences which I found
which are quite interesting apparently
they always need to look for things to
do with their tongue because in the real
in the real world they would use it to
look for food and things like this but
in zoos they don't have as much to do
with their tongue so they're just kind
of slapping it about and they also sit
down a lot which apparently doesn't
happen in the wild at least it doesn't
happen very much it certainly happens
just because there are so long and
lengthy not getting up takes a lot of
time and sitting around predators would
be a very dangerous thing to do and they
do realize that in a zoo they're pretty
much safe from any predators so they
tend to get a bit lazier in that sense
but some small differences aside they
are pretty chill animals kind of very
humble giants and quite easy to manage
as well even for a zoo as far as
charismatic megafauna goes especially so
there's certainly one of the animals
that I think you don't have to worry
about as much when you're building
habitats for them I'm just really making
sure that this habitat is large enough
for the giraffes that there's enough
enrichment to play with and some
slightly different terraforming and
things like this and aside from that I'm
also just really providing the basic
ideas of what habitat should be it
should be all visible at once by staff
members they shouldn't be able to lose
giraffe at the end of a habitat somehow
but at the same time the giraffe should
have some space to get away from the
guests while also the guests should be
able to get decent views of the giraffes
everywhere it's always a case of
balancing the needs of the giraffes the
gas
and at the same time the staff members
that need to care for the giraffes and
of course I'm also trying to attend to
the statistics in game which which is
something I should probably actually
mention in the last episode I didn't
show off the stats for the macaques or
anything like that
but the stats all ended up being okay
somehow even though I didn't you know I
built the habitat without them in it so
I couldn't really check one I was
building whether I was providing the
right foliage and the right terraforming
but it turns a bit it turned out to be
more or less okay and the same actually
goes for these giraffes
well it's even better even the foliage
and the terraforming is nearly perfectly
100% okay which I'm honestly quite
surprised about because I wasn't really
sure if it was going to work out but
yeah some people asked about statistics
and I guess I can already say that these
habitats have been fine for the animals
as far as the game is concerned so
that's a good way to to kind of test
whether your habitats are ethical as
well although I do think the size that
the game asks you to give to the animals
in terms of habitats can be on the small
side so I tend to overshoot that quite a
bit and I'm overshooting that quite a
bit with this habitat as well I guess it
is quite a large field that they get
outside here and the shelter is more
than large enough for them as well
although at the same time they do get a
lot of curious faces on top of the
shelter as well also before I forget
this at the end of this video I need to
give a shout out to nutria here on
Twitter who I've talked about doing some
of my beta videos as well as the last
video but I kept calling him the guy
whose username I forgot but gave me tips
on Twitter but I should probably stop
doing that so from now on I'm definitely
gonna remember his name he shot me it
with a message about that and I kind of
feel bad about it anyway thanks for all
the help you've given along there along
the way and I guess I'm repeating myself
at this point but please if there is any
constructive criticism
that you want to give anything that you
think I did terribly please tell me so I
can get better at this game because
nobody gets better from just people
telling them that their stuff looks cool
and there are definitely things that I
do terribly so just let me know and yeah
I think that's the only way I can
actually improve and get better at this
stuff I also had a bunch of questions in
some of the last videos whether the game
is really like this because turns out
that a lot of people are watching these
videos do don't have planets ooh but are
looking into maybe buying it and to a
lot of them it seems like this game is
all about the aesthetics and doesn't
really have any management and I have to
say this game is very management focused
and I'm not really selling exactly what
the game is about I'm just kind of
focusing on what I like to do which is
going really into the nitty-gritty of
things and trying to make things
realistic and themed but that's not
really what you have to do you can also
build simple habitats or open up a
career mode map or even download things
of the workshop and focus on
management's I think between these two
to play styles there is a balance and
and kind of sitting on one outer end of
the scale mostly focused on aesthetics
and you know the idea of how
theoretically meizu would run as opposed
to the actual gameplay but you could
certainly sit on the other side of that
balance as well so I think it's quite a
flexible game in that sense and my
videos definitely don't reflect what the
game will be like for the average person
I think you can also definitely build a
habitat in much shorter time than I
typically do if you focus a bit less on
extreme detailing either way that will
be it for this video I'd like to thank
you guys for watching and I'll leave you
with some cinematic shots bye guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you